Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
« Être
ou ne pas être. »
Pour un comédien,
vous vous dites que c’est bateau
de sortir cette phrase.
Mais vous,
vous savez qui vous êtes ?
Êtes-vous libre ?
Avez-vous laissé la vie
choisir à votre place,
ou êtes-vous parti à la conquête
de vous-même ?
Conquête.
Conquête vient du latin conquaerĕre
qui signifie chercher à prendre.
Partir à la conquête de soi-même,
c’est chercher à prendre sa liberté,
chercher et trouver là où on se sent
le mieux, là où on est le plus à l’aise.
Moi, je suis dans ma vie.
Le plus important, je ne suis pas
simple spectateur ou celui qui subit.
Je m’appelle Soriba Dabo.
Je suis comédien, j'ai 25 ans.
Ce soir, Mesdames, Messieurs,
les plus jeunes,
je vais vous dire comment
j’ai pris ma liberté
et comment j’ai cultivé ça autour de moi.
Moi,
Soriba Dabo,
je viens du clan d’Abo Kunda, un clan
établi en Afrique subsaharienne.
Et quand on vient de cette famille,
on est fier d’être de cette famille.
Quand tu es un Dabo, tu es fier
d’être un Dabo, c’est comme ça.
C’est ma famille Dabo,
ou plutôt ma famille d’abord.
Et mes parents ont toujours
voulu garder ce lien
avec ceux qui sont restés en Afrique,
rester proches malgré la distance.
Et ça s’est vu dans l’éducation
qu’ils m’ont apportée.
J’ai grandi avec mes frères et sœurs,
tous mes cousins, toutes mes cousines.
On était constamment ensemble,
il n’y avait pas de différences.
Mes cousins et cousines sont
comme mes frères et sœurs.
Il y a des valeurs fortes qu'on partage
et qu'on doit véhiculer.
Être responsable de soi, veiller
au bien des autres, penser à l’unité
et penser à soi.
Faire partie de la famille,
c'est penser à soi aussi.
Prendre soin de soi, ça fait du bien
aux tiens, à ceux qui t’aiment.
Par exemple, quelqu’un de chez moi
qui part loin pour faire ce qu’il aime
et s’épanouir, tout en pensant à nous ?
On est super content pour lui.
Le principal pour la famille,
c’est l’amour qu’on donne aux autres
et qu’on donne à soi-même.
Si je suis heureux,
ils seront heureux pour moi.
Être là où mon cœur bat.
Faire ce qui a du sens pour moi,
c’est une victoire pour toute ma famille.
J’ai grandi à Nantes
dans un quartier qui s’appelle Bellevue,
un quartier dit « sensible ».
Une vraie chance pour moi
d’avoir grandi là-bas.
J’ai rencontré des humains incroyables,
des gens comme Tony, Maxime, Jimmy, Latif.
Des gens avec qui j’ai tissé des liens
qui sont comme des liens du sang,
ce sont mes frères.
On a galéré ensemble l’été quand
on ne pouvait pas partir en vacances.
On se tournait les pouces
toute l’année sur le parking.
Et aujourd’hui, on conçoit
nos projets artistiques ensemble.
On part en vacances ensemble.
On a fait face à la galère ensemble
et quand le bon plat est servi,
on festoie ensemble, on mange,
on boit, on rit ensemble.
Une équipe comme les Power Rangers.
(Rires)
Aah, les Power Rangers, ça vous parle !
Power Rangers, Dragon Ball Z.
Ah la la la la ! Quelle époque !
Je regardais ça
et je pensais que je pouvais faire
comme Sangoku et Végéta.
Qu’en criant de toutes mes forces,
j’allais me transformer en Super Saiyan.
Que mes cheveux noirs,
ils allaient devenir blonds comme eux.
Je regardais beaucoup
les Power Rangers aussi.
Ils arrivent en équipe, ils terrassent
tous les méchants.
Le Power Rangers bleu, le rouge,
le jaune, le rose, plein de couleurs.
Moi c’était le bleu, mon préféré.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi,
ce n’était pas le chef,
mais sans lui, ce n’était pas pareil.
Donc grâce au Power Ranger bleu,
le bleu est devenu ma couleur préférée.
Vu que je vois que ça rigole -
on est entre nous -
je vais vous faire une petite confidence :
chez moi, jusqu’au lycée,
je prenais une serviette, je la mettais
autour de mon cou en guise de cape
et je me prenais pour Sangoku de Dragon
Ball Z ou pour le Power Rangers bleu
et je me battais contre plein
de méchants imaginaires.
J’avais cette liberté
de croire être l’un des leurs.
Je prenais tellement de plaisir
à le faire que, très tôt, je me suis dit :
« Ça doit être ça la vie :
faire sans se mettre de barrières. »
On peut tout faire,
mais pas n’importe quoi.
Oui, vraiment tout.
Et quand on sent que
ce qu’on fait est juste
et que la barrière ne veut pas se lever,
c’est là qu’il faut l’enfoncer
pour continuer à être libre.
Oui.
Le fait d’être cette personne,
qui aime se frotter à des choses
nouvelles, découvrir, explorer,
m’a fait comprendre une chose :
je ne voulais pas seulement
être libre en tant qu’individu.
Je ne voulais pas seulement
casser quelques barrières.
Je voulais qu’il y ait des travaux
pour qu’il n’y ait plus de barrières,
pour qu’on puisse changer
les paramètres en groupe.
Et se dire : «Merci pour les travaux.»
J'ai commencé le cinéma
par de la figuration.
Pour une série télévisée.
Et après ça, je me suis dit :
«J’aime cet univers,
être devant la caméra, faire vivre
un personnage avec tout un décor,
voir toute une équipe
rendre ça possible.»
Je me suis dit : «il faut que je fasse !
Soriba, il faut que tu fasses.»
Mais je ne savais pas comment faire,
je ne savais pas comment avoir de rôle,
comment aller dans ce milieu.
Donc,
j’ai décidé de créer une websérie.
Et j’ai tout de suite voulu faire ça
avec ceux qui m’entourent.
On parle de cinéma, on parle de scénario,
il y a plein d’idées qui fusent
et je me dis : « Waouh !
Avant ça, on n'avait jamais parlé
de cinéma concrètement.
Et là, on veut faire, on veut avancer,
on est débutant, mais on s’en fiche,
on veut juste aller loin. »
Donc on fait ce projet de websérie.
Après ça, je décide de me former,
de devenir comédien
et je quitte les miens quelque temps.
Je rejoins un programme d’acteurs national
initié par le Théâtre national
de Strasbourg.
Donc, je vais en Alsace
parce que je me dis que le fait
d’engranger le plus de connaissances,
le plus de pratique, me faire un réseau,
vont me permettre de passer
de figurant à premier rôle.
Oui,
pour moi,
le théâtre,
le cinéma,
ont été une révélation.
Je veux interpréter des rôles,
je veux raconter des histoires.
C’est là où je me sens
le plus libre et à ma place.
Donc,
je vais en Alsace.
Et pendant mes études de théâtre,
je tombe sur des textes qui me parlent
énormément et les mots me touchent.
J’avais déjà cet amour pour les mots,
mais là, je tombe sur des textes
qui me bouleversent,
qui me façonnent,
qui m’éduquent en quelque sorte.
Je comprends le sens de certaines
choses différemment.
Ça fait écho chez moi d’une autre manière
et ça réveille davantage ma sensibilité.
Et je me pose des questions.
Je me dis :
«Pourquoi n’ai-je pas eu connaissance
de ces textes avant ?»
Si j’étais resté à Bellevue,
aurais-je eu connaissance de ces textes ?
Pourquoi personne ne m’a parlé
de ces textes qui me nourrissent tant ?
En parcourant ces textes, je pense
aux miens, à mes amis, à ma famille.
Et je me dis qu’eux aussi pourraient
être touchés par ces textes.
Donc, je décide de rentrer à Bellevue pour
combiner artistiquement avec les miens.
Je prends des textes de Bernard-Marie
Koltès, de Pablo Neruda, d'Aimé Césaire,
de Jean-Luc Lagarce
et je dis à mes amis qu’on allait
mettre ça en scène devant une caméra
avec notre touche originale,
notre idée originale.
Oui, on vient de cités, on a nos codes,
on a nos façons de faire
et on peut mettre en scène
des textes de théâtre.
Bon, je vous avoue qu’au début
ils n’étaient pas trop chauds,
mais ils m’ont fait confiance -
je vous l’ai dit, l’esprit Power Rangers.
Donc, on fait ce projet,
Il prend de l’ampleur.
Et un jour, l’un d’entre eux me dit :
«Mais en réalité, Pablo Neruda,
ce qu’il dit dans son texte,
c’est exactement ce qui se passe
chez nous, dans notre quartier.
Combien de jeunes meurent lentement
parce qu’ils ne lisent pas,
parce qu’ils ne voyagent pas,
parce qu’ils ne savent pas
trouver grâce à leurs yeux ?»
Et là, on plonge dans les eaux profondes.
On va aller chercher à explorer l'inconnu.
On va aller chercher notre sensibilité,
notre fougue, notre bravoure,
notre amour pour soi et pour les autres.
Oui, ici la littérature, on se l’approprie
pour notre évolution,
pour notre épanouissement.
Nager dans les eaux profondes
sans se frotter à la barrière de corail.
Mais en réalité, si votre bonheur,
votre liberté
se trouvent au-delà de la barrière
de corail, allez-y, allez-y !
Je suis comédien pour ça aussi.
Pour me surprendre, pour me surpasser,
pour découvrir plein
de nouvelles facettes de moi
et me dire :
« Ah, je touche du doigt des rêves
que je ne pensais pas pouvoir réaliser.»
Je pense sincèrement
que c’est important de changer
les paramètres de son existence.
Quand on ne se sent pas au bon endroit,
quand on n’est pas à l’aise,
ne craignez rien.
Laissez-vous faire.
Vous avez en face de vous un être
qui veut seulement entendre
une autre respiration,
écouter un autre cœur qui bat.
J’ai cassé toutes les vitres
et sauté par la fenêtre
pour pouvoir toucher un autre être.
C'est un désir qui me prend
certains soirs.
Comme ce soir.
« Vous n’avez en face de vous
qu’un esprit trop profond pour rester seul
et enfermé. »
Ça, c'est Bernard-Marie Koltès.
Grâce à mon entourage,
j’ai pris conscience de
la valeur que j’avais.
J’ai avancé.
J'ai découvert le cinéma,
le théâtre, les mots.
Je me suis conquis.
Et aujourd’hui,
je suis prêt à nager
dans toutes les eaux du monde.
Avec ceux que j’aime.
L'humilité d'un bras droit.
Et la force d'un leader.
Voilà ce qui fait la personne.
Reste conforme, même s'il y a des sommes.
La vie se résume en quelques tomes.
Écoute bien,
pour être en rythme face au slalom.
Sache que tous les chemins
ne mènent pas à Rome.
Puis les ratures de la vie
ne s’efface pas à la gomme.
Se digèrent avec le temps.
Avec le cran.
Ce n’est pas en se regardant dans
le miroir qu’on peut sentir son être,
mais en fermant les yeux,
qu’on trouve sa lumière.
Faire.
Et refaire.
Une fois qu’on a nos repères,
additionnez tout cela à ceux qu’on aime.
Explorer les eaux profondes.
Que la pluie transperce
tout l’accoutrement.
Un esprit critique qui décortique.
Une âme sensible qui pleurniche.
Un humain sincère, poétique.
Une vie entière sans fléchir.
Ce que je souhaite.
Un esprit critique qui décortique.
Une âme sensible qui pleurniche.
Un humain sincère poétique.
Une vie entière sans fléchir.
Je le souhaite pour tous.
Ça, c’est moi,
Soriba Dabo.
Merci infiniment pour votre écoute.
(Applaudissements)